so my background actually is not in
computer security although I I try to
work in computer security my background
is in fault-tolerant computing and so
that's how I first met subhasis and I'm
really honored that you all invited me
here to give this talk today and about
the mid-90s I got interested in what if
these impairments to to proper
functioning were intentional rather than
accidental and started to think about to
what extent could some of the ideas from
fault-tolerant supply when building
systems that have to operate in the
presence of malicious attacks so that's
what I'm going to talk about today and
it's a fairly broad talk I hope that's
of interest to all of you covering a lot
of ground and I hope you'll feel free to
engage me in any way you want to as as
we go along so you see there's a couple
of words in the title engineering so
we're trying to turn a craft of
cybersecurity into an engineering of
cybersecurity pragmatic in that I've
really struggled with this that for
small systems and in very limited
applications we can actually do proofs
about things and that has been a way
that the field has gone for for many
years and what you're going to see here
is a little bit more mushy and a little
more engineering but I think that it's a
away a potential way forward as we move
forward so I'll start by just showing
you a quote of questionable value but as
I was thinking about this talk and
thinking about why I've done the things
I've done over the last say 10 or 15
years and working in this field is
trying to first understand what the
realities are what are we dealing with
and I think the introduction that was
given is
is a really good introduction to talk
about some of the complexities I think
we have a lot of misconceptions about
what is what is reality and what is
fantasy when it comes to thinking about
attackers when it comes to thinking
about what's possible in systems and
what I hope will do is a beginning of
starting to think about resilience
seeing them in in a in a I hesitate to
say more scientific way but but starting
to move move towards that I should say
that there's interest in this kind of
approach more generally much more
general than then I work in NSA is now
funding a set of science of security
centers one of those is that Illinois
some of this work is is funded by that
Center but really groups of people
trying to think more fundamentally about
how we can get out of the challenge
we're really in today so here's some
things i'll call facts i mean there are
definitely not things that that we have
proofs of but this is the basis for the
approach I've thought about and I've
taken as we move forward first I think
we would all agree that the kind of
cyber systems were living with today are
very very complex and despite our best
attempts to say simplify things to be
able to have more assurance about them
they're only becoming more and more
complex so the kind of systems I think
about I do a lot of work in cyber
security related to the power grid I've
done work and other large
telecommunications infrastructure 'he's
these kinds of things you know we're not
talking about complexity at the level of
single chip a single board these kind of
things what we're thinking about
large-scale distributed computing
systems that in many cases are connected
to the
go world and in which there can be
consequences second statement that that
I'm guided by is that absolute
cybersecurity is unattainable when we
first started working in this field in
the mid to late 1990s there was a
program at DARPA called intrusion
tolerant systems it was founded on the
basis that we needed to tolerate some
intrusions being successful rather than
finding a way to build a fort knox and
avoiding all successful intrusions and
was very interesting program a lot of
things worked on in that program and i
can remember visiting a DOD of bass and
and and and talking about this idea that
we needed to process the tax just like
we process faults and fault tolerance
systems and i can remember the the
military person who is in charge of a
large infrastructure more or less just
wanting to throw us out of the room
saying that's crazy i need you to build
a system in which there are no attackers
on my MILNET don't tell me how to build
a system that there can be attackers on
my MILNET and you can tolerate it so
there's been a long history of what i
think is fantasy of saying that that we
we must go for these systems that are
impenetrable so if we believe that we
can't make perfect systems then we need
to think at a higher level and we need
to build systems that somehow can
operate through attacks now this means
that we have to have a more operational
notion about what we mean by proper
performance so we need to have we need
to have a spec for what we the system
should do and we need to them preserve
that and that spec could be related to
an availability a delivery of service it
could be
related to confidentiality of certain
information but we have to think at that
higher level in terms of the spec and we
need to be able to operate through
constant attacks some of them being
partially successful in such a system so
that's that's the starting point for
what we're trying to do that doesn't
absolve us from trying to protect the
best we can so in in the approaches that
I'm going to talk about we need to use
as much if you will from classical cyber
security as we can to to protect to
avoid attacks from being successful but
we have to realize that that some
attacks will be successful and so we we
have to have ways to do detection we
have to have ways to do response just to
jump in advance here's the cover
potential things like election in
security yeah we actually had some prior
talks on I'm not going to specifically
talk about that we you know i i've heard
some things about those kind of things i
think what you're pointing out is that
you don't have to corrupt it all of an
election you just have to make your
cheek yes that's right so so I think
what you're pointing out that there are
some classes of attacks and some
definitions of proper operation that
that you can recover from in some you
can't write and so some so I think this
is not going to be an approach that
works in every case but it but yeah
there are many subtleties let's get into
it and we can come back to it if you
want okay so protect the best you can
but realize that you have to detect and
respond as you as you go forward now
once you adopt this approach if you if
you'll let me adopt it and this was
something at least that I think was very
controversial
say 10 years ago or 15 now maybe its
controversial it maybe it isn't based on
the circles you're in but then
assessment becomes more important and by
assessment I mean trying to quantify in
some way the amount of resiliency or
amount of a security amount of whatever
your measure is a proper service that
that you can have and again the early
thinking on this talked about well if
you can't show that something is perfect
then because attackers a human because
the attacker will always do the worst
thing then then it's really the approach
is really no good at all on the other
hand from a practical point of view we
know many attackers are not not the best
attackers there are degrees of
sophistication of attackers so if we're
going to design systems that aren't
perfect we have to understand for
different characteristics of attackers
what degrees of what degrees of
protection that that they might provide
so I want to talk a bit I believe
there's a real need to be able to make
engineering trade-offs when we take this
approach to resiliency and I'm going to
talk about at least directions on how to
do that
an elevation of skill because people
sell attacks yes they sell gluten tax
they don't sell that attacks yeah it's
elbows but Gresham's law doesn't seem to
apply for some reason so can you really
rely on bad attackers when when the bad
guys are you can rely on routine best
practices yeah yeah so you clearly have
to understand that that's going on you
you attackers have many motives and when
we get to what rotana attackers may have
an aversion to cost or they may not an
attacker may have a attacker may worry
about detection and may not right and so
what I mean is that you have to think
about what motivates the attackers we
have to write down in a way different
classes of attackers that are motivated
by different things and then we can use
those nature's of attackers to try to
explore in an engineering base way what
we think those attackers will do and and
how likely they are to succeed so and
again I'll get into this more in the
details but i'm not trying to perfectly
assess i'm not trying to say like what
you'd love to say in a full torrent
system this is a 59 system no more than
four minutes per year down time right
I'm I'm trying to say if I have this
kind of security control i could use or
that kind of security control for this
kind of architecture can I have an
engineering basis for saying that I
should choose a over B and and and right
now we don't have that we have wizards
we have people that are very wise and
probably often make the right decisions
but we don't have ways in which we can a
show that those were the right decisions
and we don't have ways as the kind of
things you suggest happen as the
attackers evolved knowing when how to go
back and reassess those decisions were
made so again this is why the the
pragmatic but not perfect comes in the
almost an apology for not being perfect
but it's that that doing this is better
than the not doing this okay and then
finally maybe this is just more of a
cartoon but I've seen for so long
because that the research community has
been stifled because they would say
things like well if I cannot prove that
approach to resiliency or cyber security
is perfect then it can't be used because
attackers are too good and they will
always get through or I've seen an
argument that if I can't because
attackers a human so we don't know how
to model humans then cyber security
metrics are impossible so we should just
do nothing and so what I'm going to
argue ideas for and what I show you is
that that that we need to press forward
and we need to to begin in a very early
way that established this if you will
scientific approach or engineering
approach to resiliency that we're going
to have to move forward even if we can't
show things that are perfect okay so
what am I trying to achieve what's the
goal the goal is to provide assured
trustworthy system operation and hostile
environments so it's a broad goal
large-scale systems think power grid
thinks other kinds of infrastructures
like that I want them to be trustworthy
what do I mean by trustworthy I use the
definition from the National Research
Council from around the turn of the
century that this says a trustworthy
system that does is one that does what
it's supposed to do in nothing else
maybe it has to be available maybe it
has to be secure maybe it has to be safe
whatever the properties related to
proper operation are it should do that
and it shouldn't do things outside that
behavior what do I mean by hostile
environment I mean an environment that
could be malicious attacks and I'm going
to generally focus on that but a system
can become untrustworthy because of
accidental failures it can be
it become untrustworthy do design flaws
and I'd like to build systems that that
if possible can tolerate each of these
kinds of impairments and to the extent
possible tolerate them in a in a unified
way one of the conjectures is or one of
the the guiding principles in design is
that if we build systems that can detect
effects of some of these kinds of
hostile environments then the cause of
the effect is less important and we can
act on that effect and we will get to
that as we go forward and then I think
another challenge in doing all of this
is that that these are systems that are
not only cyber but these are systems
that have physical components these are
systems that have social aspects and
somehow we have to consider all of that
as we go forward okay and then finally
in order to have this assuredness in our
behavior we need that we need to do some
of the assessment that we talked about
so if we think of this as an engineering
process there's nothing very deep here
but we need some requirements we this
will lead to some design hopefully
design lead some architecture will have
some assessment that assessment can
feedback and either changes in the
requirements or changes in the design
and so forth and what I'm going to talk
about today is some of the work we've
been doing both on the designs and
architecture side and on the assessment
side and again this is a this is an
early I think that we don't have
solutions but I think we can show you
some pass forward okay so let me start
with a design and architecture so a
common way of thinking about complex
systems is that you've got some system
whatever it might be just a cartoon here
you've got monitoring going on in that
system the results from those monitors
whether those are intrusion detection
systems or their other kind of
monitors whether their host level modhri
are providing information in some sort
of form to an operator the operator
tries to make sense of those things ah
something's going on here I need to take
action some actions can be taken and and
and and the system can adapt so what are
the challenges with us and I've seen
this and for example control rooms in
which they're trying to manage large
cyber infrastructure as well the
challenge is off on our that so much
that sensor data flows in that the
operators can be overwhelmed I was in
the control room once for a power grid
in which they were managing both the
cyber side of the network and the
physical side of the network and adds
these very nice display showing how
power flow was running on a
minute-by-minute basis and on the cyber
side they had a bunch of they had
several large screens screens like this
on the wall in which snorty attack our
sorry snort alerts were just flowing on
those and and I say well how do you tell
when something's going wrong how do you
tell when there's a problem in the snort
system and they they said to me well you
know you see how that pattern sort of
repeats itself some short lines and then
some long lines and short lines you know
something was really going on the sort
of pattern of alerts might change and
and I'd sense that and then I'd dig into
it and I tried to do something I think
we need to do much better than that so
what do what do I think we need to do we
need to put we need to not take the
human out of the loop we need to we need
to allow the human to interact with the
system at a level of abstraction that
that makes sense with regard to them
being able to understand things so we
put some intrusion response system in
but there's still a lot of questions
about how you would build such a system
one question is how do I know when I'm
in a good and bad state how do i how
secure is that the state of the system
that I'm in and how can I Drive the
systems to states that that
that may be more or less secure second
question is can I trust the monitors how
do I quantify the fact that the monitors
may be bad what's what's the confidence
level I have in their output what are
the actions what are the costs of the
action what are the possible outcomes of
the actions will they do what they're
intended so what I want to do now is
talk about a notional architecture that
we've been using and others that have
been doing this kind of work I mean
using to think about how one might build
one of these kind of response systems
and I'm going to once i argue that this
is a reasonable notional architecture
then I'll talk about some of the work
we've been doing in each of the areas
okay so to start and you can see here
there are three areas things you do on a
longer time scale with offline and
online things that need to be do done
during runtime and online and things
that you need to build to make sure this
kind of infrastructure would actually
work so at the offline level both
offline and and with the update on
online we believe that you need to have
some world view of your system you need
to have a state model if you will of the
system with regard to its cyber security
state you need to understand are you in
a good state are you in a bad state how
far are you away from a bad state and we
believe that you need methods to encode
into the world view model knowledge
about knowledge about what you know
about the architecture of the system and
how it should perform that worldview
then tells you something about since
you're going to try to learn about that
state of the system in real time that
suggests that that can be used to drive
how you place monitors in the system and
once again today monitors in systems
that intend to be a resilient is off all
too often done in an ad hoc way so we'd
like to have a way to approach placing
monitors in a system both at the network
level in the host level in order to give
us the information we need to have this
situational awareness in the in the more
online function we need to think about
how we actually do the monitoring and
approach that we take is to try to build
in very diverse monitors that can that
are not typically thought of working
together and find ways to correlate
those diverse monitors and in order to
gain more knowledge about the system so
that so the work in and how how we do
what mod or should we select how should
we fuse that information together needs
to be done once we have that information
that we need to think about ways of how
to how to recommend to that operator
responses that should be taken either
recommend or take those take those
responses automatically there are many
things you might want to do and I think
a very important way when you think
about this kind of response is because
you're operating on on a on a state of
the system rather than reacting to very
specific attacks that you you have the
potential to do things such as tolerate
zero-day attacks so there may be we
can't make a system in which we can
avoid all zero-day attacks right people
people are going to come up with new
ways to break into your system but if
you're operating on a state change that
is an effect of that attack then
potentially you can drive the system in
the right direction even if it's an
attacks you haven't known about before
and then finally one of the risks is
that you you you need your building
extra complexity in the system right I
started by saying systems are complex
and that's a problem and and
so you need to build you need to find a
way to make this infrastructure itself
trustworthy now there are that's a
challenging engineering problem in
itself but I believe just as in fault
tolerant computing that that it's easier
to make a smaller portion of the system
trustworthy than the entire system
trustworthy right so the argument here
is that we use the best cyber security
techniques we can to Purdue or to to to
protect this resiliency architecture
okay so what are the challenges if you
think about this approach i mean that's
that's a way of looking at the problem
what are the challenges first adaptation
inherently increases the attack surface
of the system right if you build one of
the the risks of building a system
that's adaptive is the attacker would
use that system to drive it into a bad
state right so so adaptation can help
you but adaptation can be used by the
attacker potentially as well we know how
to build an instrument systems much more
than we did in the past so we can we can
do much more monitoring than we can do
in the past but there's so much data
right just I gave you a very simple
example of monitoring in it in a power
grid control situation but there's so
much data coming in how do we make sense
of it monitors can be corruptible right
they may be providing incorrect
information so we need em for we need
ways to tolerate the fact that not all
monitoring data itself will be trusted I
believe that the approach of the world
model is very useful why because the
world model encodes things about the
system that you know are true because
you understand something about the
design but there's always a risk if you
get something wrong about the world view
model the attacker can jumps outside the
assumptions you made in that world view
model and again once take you out of
take you out of territory in which your
resiliency system can can reason and
then finally if we hope that these
catastrophic failures the failures that
really result in a deviation from the
proper performance you're trying to
achieve or rare and if you base your
responses on a statistical data that
you've learned this can cause a problem
right it's difficult to reason upon
events that are rare but but have impact
so these are all things that I think are
real challenges as you move forward but
I think there once again these are
things that that these are things that
if we think about the kind of systems
that we have to deal with today we we
have to move forward but we just have to
think about as we recently so let me
give you a couple of examples that
motivated old examples that motivate
some of the work we're doing this first
one is a an e-commerce system with
accidental failures this was based on
work we were doing with AT&T research
some time ago they were building a what
they in took intended to be a
fault-tolerant a application server a
web application server so it's a typical
sort of three tier architecture where we
start with a redundant access to web
applications that that the there are
application servers that actually
provide the services that you want and
there's a back-end database that
actually provides the services this was
modeled after work that our troubles
that AT&T people saw in large-scaled web
applications they were using to monitor
that the telephony network and the how
do you think about this if you want to
make this resilient well you need to
think about what default
models are these are the fault models we
considered we considered that that parts
of this application could crash we're
thinking about that they could be zombie
faults in the sense that they could they
could not go into a state where they
don't provide the intended service they
don't proper functionally but whatever
the sensor was that was trying to detect
that as at the host level that Center
failed and did not alert that the thing
was a zombie if we think about what kind
of recovery actions we need to take and
so when you analyze such a system you
need to think in this case you could
reboot hosts and that would affect in
this case both of the applications
running on the host or you could restart
components there are two kinds of
monitors in this system there's
individual component monitors but they
only can detect crashes there's
end-to-end path monitors they can detect
crashes and zombies but because they're
just detecting whether certain paths of
functionality work they have trouble
they have trouble isolating where the
fault occurs and the measure that we
were trying to optimize here with the
minimize the fraction of loss requests
so our rest request coming in there's
some perceived a V availability of this
service and we'd like to build an
infrastructure such that this provided
the greatest user level availability how
do we go about doing this and we did
this again this is a simple drawing but
we did this based on using data from
real data centers in eight AT&T well we
came up with a bayesian update scheme in
which using information we had about the
trustworthiness of monitors we'd create
something called a belief state the
belief state would be so in the world
view model the world view model would be
a simple model in which each one of
these components and hosts would either
be up and down
but a belief state would give us a
probabilistic notion of what what state
we were in so the state was the
probability distribution over possible
states in the world view model of the
type I talked about earlier based on
knowledge about a belief state we then
use a Markov decision process approach
based on so we call it partially
observable markov decision process
because it's on the belief state and we
can compute based on the belief state or
based on probabilistically where we
believe the system is from the monitors
we can compute actions that that should
be taken based on those actions we can
carry out those actions that leads to
more sensor data that leads to a new
belief state and the process repeats
itself so this is an example of a way to
approach resiliency for accidental Falls
you notice we don't model an attacker we
assume that that nature in a stochastic
way is changing the state of the system
due to failures based on that the
decision end engine of a markov decision
process tells us when we should modify
the system and so forth so that just
gives you a feeling of the way we
implemented a real version of this we
built simulations of this system and in
larger systems we drove it from data
that we got from AT&T and we could show
how well the decision Asian and the and
the Bayesian estimators could predict
and respond to failures compared to too
naive estimators okay so that's an
example of how how you might go for it
so so we compared it and I didn't show
that I didn't show that here but we can
heard it in two ways we compared it
against some naive ways of doing this
table lookup kind of things we can
imagine and we also compared it against
an Oracle and an Oracle would be a
system since we were simulating all this
we knew where the faults were right we
compare it against so in a sense it came
close and I don't remember the numeric
Wells but it came close to Oracle type
performance but it did so with
significantly reduced overhead with
regard to the actions that need to be
taken so there are certain to estimates
to how you quantify this right how good
do you do and how much overhead you
incur in doing it and so you know you
can do you you could do fairly well and
you significantly reduce the the
overhead in order to do it so that was a
that was an accidental approach just to
show you where we're going then the next
thing we thought about is well what if
these are malicious attacks okay what if
what if we now not have Mother Nature a
changing state but we have a deliberate
attacker changing the state well now we
have to think about a two-player game we
have to think about possible goals of
those attackers how is that attacker
going to have a goal and we have to
think about possible responses that we
would take in in in the in the in the in
the realm of those attacks we did that
by using something called an attack
response tree an attack response tree is
a generalization of an attack tree
something that's use a very simple thing
just like a fall tree that's used in
analysis of secure systems and that the
attack tree had leaf nodes that were
alerts run so think of the attack tree
as a as a function that denotes progress
of an attacker towards a goal in real
time on the system so on the bottom
there you see IDs alerts you see
square nodes there that are sub goals
that attackers might take there's logic
in the tree that looks at the attackers
progression in those attacks steps are
those sub goals and that part is like a
normal attack tree they think of it as
almost a dashboard that's monitoring
perceived progress of attackers towards
goals look the top event is in a goal an
attacker might take and you see on the
side there what's different is you you
notate certain of the nodes with
possible responses so the responses are
actions that you could take in the
system from your knowledge of the the
system the world view like I showed you
before but their responses that you
could take at a certain level that if
successful those responses would correct
think of overtime as the attacker is
advancing certain sub-trees of this are
are becoming red as the attacker makes
progress that could make a response that
could recover from an attack that's
progressed to that level and so there
are trade-offs to be made right do you
immediately respond at a low level when
you see that there's a potential attack
going on or is it better to wait and
respond at a higher level that could
have a larger effect mitigating the
problem of the attack as you on so again
there's their trade often since
something people deal with every day you
know do I fight a lot of small fires or
do I fight bigger fires and and what are
the consequences of one over the other
this is assistant this is running in
real time what I'm telling you do you
mean is the system itself real timer is
this exactly so what this is I won't
show you a picture like this but there's
a execution loop just like this state is
being monitored state is being monitored
now what's here is in a Markov decision
process but as
of these attack response trees and the
attack response tree can be compiled
into a two player game a two player game
in which in real time the state of where
I am in that game is is being estimated
and then once again i can compute based
on costs i assigned to the responses and
and and through where I tag the
responses on the tree the effect that
those responses can have I can I can
then compute optimal responses to take
as an attack is progressing so think of
this thing is running as the as the
system is going on guiding an operator
saying this is the attacker this this is
where I think the state is and this is
the response that I I recommend that you
take based on that level yes that can oh
did I carry young mature yep smart you
know you understand how to respond to
different levels exactly is going to
make some adjustments on the fly exactly
and you said you know these become
adapted you know open to another remote
attacks that's right that's right this
is contrary way it sits so if you
believe that any adaptation is so bad
that that you should not use not yeah
yeah yeah yeah no I said this was a
challenge and I said it wasn't perfect
but but we build adaptive systems every
day we build adaptive systems today in
which a human's reconfigure systems
based on the purview of the state of the
system what I'm proposing here is that
rather than having humans make those
decisions these kind of approaches can
help guide them make those decisions as
you go along do that this decision
instead of human because this is stuff
happening so fast that's right so what
we believe and again as we talk to
people in industry that are thinking
about these kind of approaches we
leave that that as we push this forward
that you can imagine a an advisory
system some decisions some decisions at
a low level you might make automatic you
might you there they're not very risky
you you might take them automatically
some responses involve a costs
significant costs and you can quantify
costs in different way you know costs
could be unavailability costs could be a
financial cost imagine a system that
rather than just being if you're in a
control room rather than just being
presented with the rather than just
being presented with the alerts you're
presented not only with the alerts but
some higher-level indication of how the
attacker is moving through the system
and you're presented with options you
can say I recommend that the the most
efficient response is this would you
like to take that response and so what
we believe this can be used for is in a
combined way with the human helping a
human be better in making those
decisions you try to make it comparable
to in your system basically an immune
system yes far away oh yes were the
perfection you know we're in your body
detecting the infection ashura sponsor
so in the human world since we don't
have that sophistication in the
technology available to us we don't have
that sort of understanding and croaking
oh Lisa stuff so wouldn't be better to
the starting proactive rather than
reactive because instead of you know
having me through the coming to your
house you can get and you have this
performance issues that cause associate
to dip & M by M and by proactive what
what would you give me an example of
proactive would it be reacting earlier
you your monitoring the state farther
away from the house and you're reacting
earlier or
God whose companies employing and you
can do a lot of people are in poor
relations okay so so I'm I'm not
disagreeing with that approach I'm not
arguing specifically that this kind of
game theory works better than a deep
learning approach we see in practice but
again this is a very early stage that
deep learning with no world view model
on systems that are this complex is at
least I have not seen any evidence of
those i mean if i'd be happy to talk to
you more of this offline but but but
this is a system that observed state
just like the system you talked about
and makes it and makes recommendations
or it makes decisions depending on how
much you trust that about actions that
should be taken but your existing 16
unit states level dad would you put into
saw five children and entering the park
okay okay let me um let me quickly give
you a few examples and I I see time is
going by fast so what I want to do now
is go back to the the general not what I
want to go back is to the general
architecture the notional eric said i
talked about and i want to show you some
work that's been going on our groups
been doing in these various areas and
these are all pieces that we that we
hope to put together so the first is
looking at worldview models and what
we've done there is we've developed a
formalism a foreign ism called cyber
physical topology model in which we use
to write these worldviews there's a
notion of concepts the concepts can
represent different elements in a system
and there's a notion of relationships
that are the arcs between the concepts
once again this is something that can be
used in online we've we've done this for
some case studies in which the the data
structures that are encoded on the arc
our updated in real time in their data
so this is a approach to try to quantify
things about the architecture of the
system that we move forward then what
about what about maunder placement right
now too often monitors are placed in a
way that is very ad hoc so how would you
go about doing that well if you look and
and this is some of what what what you
were talking about what do we do we
place the monitors we deploy those we
have some system that that takes the
results from those monitors and
constructs alerts so if we can develop a
system in which we understand that there
are very different kinds of monitors in
the system we can understand what kind
of indicators of attack each of those
monitors can each of those monitors can
generate and then eventually for each
indicator what sort of attack event do
they represent so what we've developed
is a way that uses optimization
techniques that with respect to
different with respect to different
metrics about monitors their redundancy
their coverage their costs we can say
how do we select a set of monitors that
within given constraints provides the
best monitoring this is a paper we
reported on just this summer at I Triple
E dependable systems and network
conference in fact it was the best paper
at that conference it's a technique
that's been used this summer to model
IBM's health Watson Network and look at
how do you place monitors in that
network to monitor both failures and
attack kind of behavior so that's a
that's an optimization approach that we
develop their we
started thinking about what sort of
monitors what sort of monitors diverse
monitor should we should we make we
believe that monitors that we need to go
well beyond standard intrusion detection
system kind of monitors that we need
very diverse modders and we built a
monitoring system called Cobra Cobra is
an add-on to the Windows kernel core
Brooke oh bruh at at low overhead takes
three or four percent overhead to run
this in the real test that we've done
monitors a lot of events that are going
on in the kernel it understands things
about traffic it understands things
about processes that start it
understands things about other operating
system calls and it fuses those together
it builds based on data dictionaries and
sort of sparse representation techniques
it builds a notion of the state of the
system and it uses results from from
learning to try to detect modifications
so a program for example when it runs
this this is a I think the atop a wet
web server will develop a signature like
that we can if a attack is made if a
modification to that web server has made
that will cause a change in that
signature and we can detect that so this
is an approach that we've made in which
we add very if you will deep monitoring
to the running of the operating system
in order to detect problems at the host
level what's key note some EE near an
operator D capaldi old on the left where
is the car o dese store yeah yeah he
stores yeah so this is this is a this is
a representation
the distance from a normal behavior and
this is a space in that space so we're
just looking at a difference there we've
also looked at ways in which we fused
together diverse information this is
using data from attacks that go on at
the supercomputing center Illinois we
have we have a lot of logs of attacks we
have about 200 successful attacks on
that supercomputer center we have logs
about what was going on in the firewalls
we have logs about what's going on in
the host systems and what we did is once
again using machine learning techniques
we looked at how we looked at how
diverse data could be fused together to
give more detection of attacks that
occur and that was something we did a
hot sauce then we tried to put put that
kind of monitoring together we looked at
lateral movement attacks a very common
kind of attack is where a cyst an
attacker succeeds in compromising a
system then the attacker tries to use
that system to move through it a network
system so we combined the cobra a
monitoring system on individual hosts so
this picture of the cartoon you see on
the right hand side here is a graph that
was generated showing the movement of an
attacker through processes on an
individual host and we shared that
information together in a network way in
order to look at and observe movement of
attackers across hosts and once again
we're trying to look at ways to bring
together very diverse monitoring
information in order to do overall
detection so there's examples of
works have been done and then finally
this is really the the newest work
that's going on is we're trying to make
use of all that detection system using
game theory approaches once again to
protect responses that should occur and
here's some work that's going to be
presented next month at game sack game
theory and security looking at how you
can use these use these monitoring
results in order to make decisions about
attack actions that should be taken to
push attackers away from their goals
again so these are all pieces to the
solution as I said we don't you know we
I guess the lateral movement or approach
has been used and showed how you can
push back but there's there's more work
that needs to be done let me let me
close in the or talk for the next five
minutes or so on the assessment side so
as I said we once we think we can build
these kind of resiliency approaches we
need to know how well they're going to
work what approaches should be make let
me do a little quick hypothetical which
is not necessarily where the malicious
third party um that's supposedly get a
delorean we send your sister back 1979
okay Three Mile Island is happening yep
do you think your system would have
worked in that control room at that time
when they were getting anomalous
readings of water levels inside the core
well I don't it would be very
hypothetical because I don't know very
much about exactly what happened in
Three Mile Island well there were a
bunch it there were a bunch of valves
which were thought to be I think it was
close drove and I don't think that
pretty dick dr. pretty yeah but actually
they they had to head back up emergency
coolest but the reality was that the
water world on the coral session the top
part of the core did actually begin to
melt down but the people in the control
room didn't know that because he says
since we're likely
Jane Fonda and michael douglas actually
did a pretty good movie with China
Syndrome they were they were pretty much
fun mark and the actual accident which
only not that part three weeks after the
release from a job I started as a
freshman who knows I nuclear reactors me
and Kyle good question it not my
question is if this system could go back
and I did you could so that so so if you
have no credible state information and
and what I don't know is how much in 3
ml I you have that credible state
information then know this system is
going to help isn't going to help you on
the other hand and and take the
Northeast blackout of 2003 is one that
we've studied very carefully that system
could if we had credible state
information from these kind of
approaches forget the malicious attacks
there as well because there weren't
malicious attacks but the lack of
situational awareness is really what
caused that blackout to propagate the
sensory information the system is only
the system does not rely on any sensory
input is being perfect right we the
system relies on diversed so one of our
again one of the the conjectures that
we're working on is that there can be
many small lies right sensors can tell
lies but there's not a grand lie in the
sense that human attackers will not be
smart enough in order to create the
grand lie that causes you to make all of
the wrong decisions the other approach
that we're basing this on is that you
need to provide information at a level
detection abul that's all too often I
mean what was happening in the case of
the blackout of of 2000 blackout of 2003
was that operators on the phone they had
displays the displays were telling him
completely different things and they
they they in a sense froze and didn't
take action they didn't take pre-act
action they should have taken certain
city's Cincinnati offline in order it
would keep the blackout from propagating
so so that's the kind of that's the kind
of so not perfect but credible
information at the level that it can be
actionable and very diverse sensor input
that you placed in ways that you have
knowledge the optimization that I shows
you there gives you knowledge of how
much redundancy you have in your sensor
inputs so you can tolerate some bad
information all information bad you're
no better off ok let me for not 145 oh
ok I can go a little bit farther that'll
be fine ok let me move on to trust
assessment that's just when the cameras
go off you can keep talking too late am
ah you can you can stay as long as you
want and then but ok let me talk about
trust assessment now so going back to
some of the facts that I I told you
earlier if we believe that systems
aren't perfect and we believe that
attacker is going to seek to degrade
system operation we have to understand
how to architect these systems right we
have to understand if we have a system
how should we architecture should we add
controls here should we add controls
there should we add defense in depth
here should we add defense in depth
somewhere else we can do this at design
time we can do this at operation time
when we need to reconfigure so the
bottom line is how can we compare
different approaches to architecting
these systems whether it be a resiliency
system of the type I I talked about
before whether it would be more standard
cybersecurity how can we architect these
systems what are the kind of questions
that that the people who do this would
like to to ask here's up here's security
questions that were written by that in a
grand challenges on trustworthy
computing reports some time ago at the
CIO level or the chief security officer
level they asked very high level
questions questions that are really hard
to ask I've had people from
from the government call me up and say
is our power grid more secure than it
was when Obama took office can you give
me quantification of that right good
question right to be answering a during
reelection time so these are the kind of
very high level questions down at the
technical level you'll ask questions
about is design a or b more secure have
I made appropriate trade-offs between
timeliness security and costs how will
the system as implemented respond to a
specific attack scenario what's the most
critical part of the system to test from
a security point of view how can I focus
on these things these are all things
that we'd like to be able to ask even
harder questions are how did the
technical metrics on the on the right
hand side relate to the high level chief
security officer metrics so what I'd
like to do is think about the way we
answer those questions today and the way
I think we should answer them tomorrow
so what's the situation today situation
today is really comes in two forms one
form is there's an expert a wizard the
people we've worked with in the
government the people we've worked with
in companies there's there's there's a
wise person who says I believe that you
should spend more money on firewalls I
believe we need to educate people I
believe we need to fill all the USB
ports on computers so no we can put a
memory stick yet so so these might be
the right actions in order to increase
security but we don't know which ones
are the right ones and even if they are
the right ones we don't know why that
decision is being made another way these
kind of decisions are often made is it
in collective way people realize that
cybersecurity is a very very
multifaceted problem they understand
that there are experts in network
operations they understand there are
experts in human behavior they
understand that they're experts and how
we should educate a workforce
and often these people get together they
get around the table I've heard this set
in settings that this is five guys in a
bottle of wine they all get together
they talk about the problem they make
decisions about what approaches they
should take the trouble with these kind
of approaches is there's no way to audit
the decisions that are made there's no
quantifiable ranking of alternative
options and over time as the situation
the security situation changes there may
be no way to know whether the decision
should be reconsidered so once again
this is a case of for many years people
have said well it's too hard to have
metrics of security we shouldn't try
because because it's too hard to give
perfect answers you know in the dream
world we'd like to be able to tell us
the likelihood of an attack on on some
sort of computing infrastructure that's
successful and has this kind of effect
is less than pick your your number less
than one in a thousand in one year right
what I'd like to argue is that even if
we can't achieve those kind of goals we
we we can do better than just what we do
on the left hand side we'd like to build
tools that enable diverse stakeholders
to express their opinions to express
them in a common language in which we
can reason about different design
alternatives we'd like to quantify
different approaches to cybersecurity
and we'd like to have a way that we can
go back and audit we'd like to have a
model of the of the security assessment
process that we can look at as our
assumptions about attackers change as
the nature of the system changes we can
once again determine whether these are
the right security choices to be made
right so here's an example of what I'd
like to be able to do this is something
called an attack execution graph the
graph is something that
a security analysts would draw the I'm
only going to show you the high level
I'd be happy to give you many more
details but the the ovals cold ovals at
the bottom here are goals goals that
attackers might have the yellow our
attack steps steps that attackers might
take and the boxes and the triangles and
the green circles our knowledge about
the state of the system and the way the
state of the system is quantified in
these analysis techniques are through
access through skills through knowledge
okay and I'll show you a little more
detail how that works think of this as
an attack graph that's used in attacker
start from a certain state they start
from a certain axis skill and knowledge
attack steps may or may not be possible
by attackers attack steps have certain
costs associated with them they have
certain likelihoods of being successful
they have certain likelihoods that an
attacker who attempts them will be it
detected right so the input to the model
is the graph the output from the model
is the arrows the blue arrows that you
see on here so the tool that I'm going
to just show you a little bit about is a
tool that will take a description of the
characteristics of an attacker it will
take an attack execution graph as input
or it will help you build an attack
execution graph from a higher level
architectural model and the output will
be the inside engineer is most likely to
try that attack path the hacker of the
for government is most likely to take
this other attack path and so on so what
we'd like to do is provide that group of
people to get together that build the
attack execution graph and give some
characteristics of attackers we'd like
to give them indications of where
attackers are most likely to attack
question left no comment your left side
a box on figuring out how jump air gaps
it certainly used where well this is
yeah I don't I don't know exactly where
this is a model by the way without going
into the D so this is a model of a
district distribution side control of a
power grid where the question that was
asked is should I add these things
called recloser radios a product to the
to the architecture the advantage of the
recloser radios is that they provide
greater availability because when a
power system fault occurs and let's say
a line goes dead I can re-route power by
closing that closing that a recloser but
these r e closers have the interesting
property that they have Wi-Fi
configurability to them and so that you
can imagine an attacker using the the
Wi-Fi to to attack the system so on one
hand a one engineer and the company
might argue we should put the recloser
xin those were closer zaid at aid to
availability on the other hand they open
security risk and what's the trade-off
of the two and the folks we worked with
in general electric who produce these
products wanted to understand what the
wrists and trade-offs are of that new
product in introduction into these kind
of systems so we can argue about is this
the right attack execution graph or not
this is one that was developed for a
particular system with the GE power
engineers with the GE cyber engineers
well it's one model that assumes that
you have access to the internet and a
lots of places don't have access to the
internet and the question is it doesn't
assume that no no no it's got several
internet point says no we know we go
isn't it yeah we don't assume that what
I haven't shown you yet is these boxes
the triangle squares and the circles
take on values and depending on those
values you may or may not
have access to the to the internet so
each one of these steps has a
precondition that each one of these
steps has a preconditions and when the
conditions are right the attack step
might be able to be attempted when it
can be attempted it might be successful
does it help come on let's keep ya okay
so that's right that's just the example
okay so what did we do we built a tool
that we call advise actually this tool
has been used in in quite a few
corporate settings now to make these
kind of trade-off analysis you you build
a description of the system that's the
attack execution graph I showed you
build system you'd build a description
of the adversary I'll show you the
adversary model and you ask questions
you ask questions about the goals and
the goals that the attackers might take
from that you compile this into
executable versions of the model you
execute the model I'll tell you a little
bit about how we execute the model you
come up with some quantitative metrics
use use those metrics to make security
decisions and you may go back and and
revise the you may go back and revise
them all you may go back and revise the
system so the key the very interesting
thing and about how this works is how
the model execution works and this might
be reminiscent to some of you of
survivability models that were built at
CMU and other places some time ago in
those cases you had simulation models
like this you had system descriptions
you had pretty detailed descriptions of
what the attackers would do well those
while those why those models were
largely unsatisfying is attackers only
did things that you programmed to do oh
that you program this to do so what we
need it is a way of thinking about an
attacker bottle and and and modeling
attackers at the right level of
abstraction that that the
system itself could figure it figure out
what attackers what a what a best
attacker with those assumptions will do
so here's just a picture to give you a
feel of a tool in which you build these
various models and again this is a tool
we'd be happy to give you or let you
play with this is a picture of how you
specify an adversary so how do you
specify an adversary and here's where it
comes down you specify an adversary that
that gives indications of how how much
they're interested in being stealthy how
much they care about cost how much they
care about payoff of every type of
attack that they try to make the acts
that the attacker has a certain initial
state they come with certain skills and
these skills are variables that are
referred to in the attack steps that
specify how likely the attacker can be
successful so this is an attacker that
knows how to do traffic analysis in
order to try to thwart one of those were
closer radios this is attacker that has
a certain numeric scale of how how good
they are doing physical sabotage this is
an attacker that has a certain skill and
how good are they at guessing passwords
they have some access so this is an
attacker that has internet access as you
see here but you could take away
internet access if you didn't want them
to have it this is attacker that has
certain knowledge and this is attacker
that has certain kinds of goals so each
of these things you see here are
variables that you can define for a
specific system model in order to in
order to drive the execution process
with regard to the attack execution
grass so this is an attacker that wants
to this is an attacker whose goal is to
install vector software in a few places
as the detector doesn't care about the
other goals
okay so how does this work we take this
information we take it together with the
attack execution graph we build a
simulation but it's and this simulation
is automatically constructed from these
specifications by the tool but it's a
special kind of simulation in that on
every step the an optimization that
problem is solved that in which the tool
returns given the characteristics of the
attacker together with the state of the
system what the optimal execution of the
what the optimal next step for the
attacker to take would be based on based
on the nature of the attacker so we
execute this simulation over time each
time each time looking at what the
optimal attacks step for an attacker
with these characteristics would be and
and and and and and looking at the
success of the attacker over time so
what we have then is from that attack
execution graph and from the attacker
mile we generate a state level model
that state level model is execute that
state level model produces results so
going back to the example you can see if
we have a system that is a standard
system of the type that that is often
used and again this is a particular
system of one of the companies we're
working with it produces results that
gives you indications of what attackers
would do each of these lines has new
numbers that are associated with it that
says how likely that attack path has
been taken generally one path tends to
be dominant when you solve this this
kind of model and so you can see the
different kinds of attackers will have
different goals we envision this as a
defense tool but when we briefed this to
people on the offense side of cyber
security you can imagine this tells you
if you're that kind
attacker what you ought to be doing
right we we brief this to some of our
friends in the government and they said
can we use this as an attack tool well
every tool has both sides right so this
you can imagine as it well so that's the
output from the model now you imagine
that you add the recloser radios and the
interesting thing when you add recloser
radios to the model and again the blue
is the output from the model you see
that many of the attackers now
concentrate their effort in a different
way and so that suggests to you that
when you added that feature to the
system that you've created a path that
is a preferable path to the attacker
that is to find ways to send commands to
the closer's why kid why is that a
desirable things to do they can use that
to cut off flow of electricity and the
network so you can use this for a number
of reasons you can use this to say i
need to harden that i need to make that
attack step harder right so even if you
don't know or believe the exact numbers
of this this guides you into where you
put your effort to make the system more
secure once you harden that and what you
change some of the parameters of do you
believe you've done things that change
some of the parameters in that attack
step you can rerun the model and see how
the attackers then distribute themselves
right and again remember that an
optimization problem is being solved so
this is a if you will a worst-case
attacker with respect to the parameters
you talked about and so this is a very
typical way in which people use this to
try to architect systems in which there
aren't these single points of attack
concentration and the likelihood of
successful attack is is lower the tool
also outputs metrics like this here it
says that for the two different
alternative designs that we're looking
at and for different kinds of attackers
what are the most likely attacks and
what are the times it takes for the
attackers to reach the
so you can see as you as you change the
architecture of the system how long it
takes into a compromise is successful
and of course the exact numbers of this
depend on the numbers you put in with
regard to timing but in a relative sense
it can tell you have you improved
security or if you made security worse
by making those architectural changes in
these kinds of things so that's that's
what I wanted to show you I hope it was
a satisfying talk in the sense that it
suggested some paths forward based on
what we've observed the approach of
classical cyber security of
concentrating put purely on avoiding
attacks is not the path forward we need
to protect the best we can but we have
to realize that the tax will be
successful we need to build active
approaches to resiliency again they
don't always work if your situational
awareness is zero they're not going to
work at all but you build in situational
awareness through diversity through
optimization approaches in order to give
you the monitoring information you need
to make decisions how should you make
these decisions we're exploring game
theory we believe that a viable approach
but there might be other approaches
there might be approaches that rely much
less than a world view model the deep
learning approach that we heard about
and I think the jury's still out but we
need to begin to think about how we
quantify those different approaches on
the side of quantification on the side
of assessment once again for four
decades people said the security metrics
problem is too hard particularly
academic said it was too hard we just
can't work on it but when you look to
industry when you look to the government
that's trying to protect its systems
they are making assessment decisions but
they're making them in ways that aren't
scientific and they're making a ways
that rely on intuition even if that
intuition is good
they they we have no way to know we
don't have no way to do trade-off
analysis so we need tools such as the
advise to land better tools in order to
make progress there and once again I
think this is the beginning but I think
it's a path forward that a decade ago
was a very radical path now it's a path
in which many people think we need to
look at resiliency in this way and
there's a lot of working going on and
what are the right specific ways in
which to do it so thank you very much I
appreciate your attention and if you
like I'm happy to say as long as you
want to answer questions
you